anything the knights can do for you
so this holy lionel is
one of the most treasured items in
monstat it's the liar that barbados used
to play
with it perhaps i can help deval and
draw his gentle nature back out of this
nightmare he's going through
will it really stop stormcare from
causing more damage
of course i'm the best bard in the world
there's not a single song i do not know
no matter if it's from the past
present or future look me in the eyes
do you not find me trustworthy that one
doesn't work on a bard
so how can we get the holy liar it's
said that it's enshrined
deep within the cathedral somewhere safe
i'll go take a look around you can come
if you want
yes
let me handle this hello there sister
may the animo god bless you young bard
how can i help you
actually i know a secret that can save
monstaff from its current predicament
oh what a blessing from the god of animo
but you should report that to the
knights of fevonius
why have you come to me because you
dear sister are able to help i'd like to
borrow
the holy liar with it i'll be able to
help storm terror
please see yourselves out what it's a
vicious
dragon indeed but once the acting grand
master makes up her mind
nothing can stand in the night's way
that's simply not acceptable
wouldn't storm terror end up getting
killed that way that foolish beast
betrayed the winds
not even the god of animo themselves
would forgive it
please i'm afraid not little strange
somehow i feel so bad rejecting this
sweet child
then i guess i'm left with no other
choice
i cannot hide anymore my disciples
rejoice behold the god of animo
barbados has descended shocked aren't
you
don't you just want to cry out and
rejoice how does it feel to finally meet
the god you've been serving
if there's nothing else i'll be going
back to handle the cathedral's paperwork
now
huh she didn't even but i have at least
learned what i wanted to know
she didn't deny that the cathedral is
enshrining the holy liar
now since you're the hot shot of the
knights of favonius
maybe you can give it a shot
barbados bless you i know you
you and amp so what brings you here is
that so
not that i don't trust you it's just
that a suspicious
bard came looking to borrow the holy
liar as well he's full of nonsense and
even called himself barbados
he must be up to something there are
regulations in place for the use of the
holy liar
currently it's only used in looty
harpastum signed documents from the
grand master
seneschal and community representative
are all required
so may i see the document from the
knights of fevonius
a signed document is required without it
there's not much i can do
now if you'll excuse me i really am
quite busy as of late